ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon
show uh we are here in long island
governor meatball
has attacked it was a sneak attack
it wasn't completely unexpected
i did see the potential for this i
didn't vocalize it
because i didn't want to manifest it
i don't know who the department of
health the governor cuomo
or somebody in the governor's office
shut
down governor's comedy club
which was doing outside socially
distanced
safe shows in a tent
in a parking lot outside
and it had been open for a while and
many people had performed there
and there were no problems and nobody
had been tested positive for covet 19.
but yours truly
criticized the governor of the state of
new york
on the biggest podcast in the world
and then a few days later
a few hours before i was supposed to
perform
in the tent the shows were canceled and
governors got shut down now
i am not alleging that there is a
connection but i cannot
say there isn't a connection do you see
what i'm saying i don't know
i don't know i believe we're now in a
war
i'm in a war with this crime fan can we
be honest
they're a crime family mario cuomo
the grandfather was the governor now
this guy's the governor is brothers on
cnn
they're a crime family that chose to run
the state of new york
instead of a trucking company that's who
they
are and i don't care that chris
uh fredo uh cuomo corleone's wife
is a member of the southampton bathing
corp you can't
wash the garlic out of your dress we
smell you from a million miles away
you can walk on the beach with wasps
wearing white linen
but you smell like a three-day-old
sausage and pepper hero under the seat
of a [ __ ]
i know you try to wash that off but it
seeps out of your pores
and i did you know she's a member of the
very elite
southampton bathing corp one of the
oldest and most prestigious
beach clubs in the world
which means nothing to me
so i walked right you know out out they
you know they they have
obviously a building in a pool and an
inside that you can't get in
but there's a beach they're they're out
there they're sitting on the beach
and these wasps used to own the whole
world and now they have this small
patch of dirt in southampton and these
are
you know 800 of the wealthiest families
uh on the planet and
many of them have memberships to this
beach club and they
all drive beater old cars there it would
be
seen as grotesque to show up in a lambo
or
uh you know uh you know a bugatti
something ostentatious it is very wasp
aesthetic over there and i walked
through it i walked through the beach
part of it
you know there's women wearing like
white bonnets and kids i mean it looked
kind of like a regular
you know beach club you could t you know
the difference was that people were
reading
let's be honest that was the major
difference a couple of people had a few
books and not trashy
romance novels where there's like a guy
whose packs are busting
out of his shirt you know it looks like
some [ __ ]
you know lager you know on the front
cover of the book and
it was in harry potter it wasn't adults
reading harry potter
like a lot of the beaches i go to where
it's an adult
reading tween fiction an adult sitting
there unashamed
reading tween fiction it wasn't that
i couldn't see what the books were but i
could tell by their covers
they were not that but other than that
other than the fact that you saw people
reading
age-appropriate material it wasn't that
obvious
that it was uh so different from the
types of people that would just
normally congregate on a beach in a
well-to-do area i mean there were no
boom boxes i don't want to be racist
here and
this is going to seem racist but you
know what i mean nobody was playing
loud music there were no potato chips
nobody had a bag of lay's potato
chips nobody was sitting around
uh crunching cheese doodles
it was people that were reading quietly
talking quietly going in in the water
of course there's no phones allowed no
instagram no tick-tocking no you know
there are strict rules and christina
cuomo
chris uh fredo cuomo
corleone didn't have corona never forget
liar uh his wife christina grissom
is a member of the southampton bathing
court
do i know can i be certain that she was
not told
that i committed the social sin
of walking through the beach club that i
am not a member of
i don't know can i can i be sure can i
be certain that that did not happen
is this a war for the future of the
hamptons is this the cycles of new money
replacing old
am i locked in the same war that
vanderbilt and carnegie and rockefeller
were in i could be
but i'm ready for it i'm ready for it
i'm here fighting for your rights first
of all it is your right to die
no one's told you that it's your right
to die it's your right to die you have a
right
to die okay it is not your right to kill
other people but if if other people all
take a risk
and kill each other you're not killing
them
do you see what i mean like if everybody
decides
for example like you know we always talk
about drunk drivers what if everyone in
the car is drunk
do you know how many times i've been in
a car and everyone is drunk
and every time we'd get into an accident
all most people would laugh
nobody in the car deserved to survive
nobody
there was no innocent person in the car
there was no like
good person that had just accidentally
ended up in a car with three other
drunks on a wednesday night in long
island
leaving a bar called lisa's lounge
everybody already had blood
on their hands you see so if everybody
wants to get together and
assess the risk and go out and enjoy
some [ __ ] entertainment
which is i think their god-given right
or
state given they should be able to do
that without
the fear of reprisal from this
vindictive petty
gangster who's running new york state
and this is the play until trump um
is loses and you could hate trump you
could want trump to lose i think it
would be very
healthy for the country to have a reset
right about now but
let's just be honest if you work in the
restaurant business or if you work in
entertainment
be prepared for a rocky couple of months
because
especially if you're in a blue state a
lot of these governors
um they're not going to allow
the phases to reopen in a way that makes
people feel hopeful about the future i
think the plan is
to kind of reopen
uh gradually slowly and
i don't think a hell of a lot of
reopening is going to happen before
november
i just don't believe that and listen
that's a strategy
and it's you know because a lot of these
states don't want to get clobbered again
there's many reasons
but let's not for a minute pretend
let's not for a second pretend that
there isn't a benefit to
keeping the economy stalled
and keeping people a little terrorized
they just want you a little
nervous out there they want you
a little apprehensive out there a little
fearful they want you to know
that society is fragile
and that that is part of
a strategy to force political change in
the country
you may agree with it you may think it's
smart you may
i think it's necessary you might think
it's long overdue
but let's be very honest about what it
is it's not
i think if biden and kamala win the tone
of the coverage is going to change
trump did bungle this i think we can all
agree if we're honest
that trump didn't do a great job i don't
know how well
other presidents would have done and now
we'll never know
i mean we might know if we get a new one
in a few months
but at the end of the day the media
wants
this guy out and they're using every
opportunity
to you know act as a
partisan political
machine that's what they're doing if you
can't see that
you yourself have left the planet which
is okay
that's fine but just know that just you
can see
that and it's not all undeserved that's
the other thing
trump is not above reproach he doesn't
he deserves uh a lot of criticism he's
the last person you'd want in any type
of crisis
you know he like cuomo is petty he's
vindictive
you know you know i don't know what
cuomo did i haven't really been
following this nursing home scandal
i just know that my mother is in a
nursing home and has not died of covet
and everyone in my family's been
terribly disappointed you know we call
every day and we're like
what what is going on has everyone died
but her
has literally every person died of covet
in the nursing home system but her
this [ __ ] is sucking up tax dollars
like you have no idea
i mean shoot her in the head and just
say it's kophen
who cares they're not gonna care the
people who run this state
are [ __ ] criminals they're gangsters
to smother her with a pillow for christ
but i don't know what what he's been
doing i think he's just been putting
you know he's just let a brush fire of
covid
run through the nursing home system in
new york state
okay while
he's not canceling comedy shows
held in parking lots he spends his time
shipping sick covert patients to nursing
homes
starting a brush fire of disease
this is a guy who claims how well new
york handled covid
he fails to mention that all of the
outbreaks of kovid
from around the country originate and
emanate from
new york not shutting down immediately
and letting people leave now i'm not
saying that new york
should have shut down or it shouldn't
have shut down but let's look at the
causation of a lot of the
the coveted outbreaks came they can be
directly traced to new yorkers
so before we throw ourselves a victory
party
and before somebody pops out of the cake
and before mama starts rolling the
eggplant rollatini
and before we bring out the chafing
dishes and before we get the [ __ ]
peniela vodka and the chicken frances
and the cannolis out let's understand
that you and your state infected the
entire country yes or yes
those are just facts andrew andy
meatball they're just facts
and you could be a you can revise
history you could do whatever makes you
comfortable
you can get out and uh you know do this
dance do you desperately want to be
president
we've never had an italian president
and we never will we will have a
transgender
member of antifa before we
have uh somebody who smells like garlic
sitting in that oval office okay
criminal
understand that criminal
there's nothing really better than anti
uh
racism and because it is
allowed that's just simply why it's so
good it's
it's sanctioned it's allowed uh nobody
uh it will stop you from doing it in
fact there's only an upside to you
engaging in racism against
irish people or italians which is why i
do it so frequently
and because i know a lot of irish people
and italian people so it's kind of
it's fun to poke fun at them but i mean
if the governor let's
say let's just say for an example the
governor was a black lesbian
let's do the show again ready ladies and
gentlemen welcome to the tim dillon show
the shows got cancelled real
disappointing anyway
heading back to l.a pretty soon really
excited about
you see the difference you see the diff
and that's unfortunate
that is unfortunate because i do believe
that everybody deserves a good lashing
specifically when they are
targeting uh just a clown
just a happy clown coming to dances
clown dance for the people in long
island the
simple people in long island who just
want to laugh they just want to laugh
and eat
bacon egg and cheese sandwiches and
occasionally do a little heroin
that's all they want to do they want to
live in houses they inherited and
complain about the tax burden
ah six trillion dollars already spent on
covert 19
the national debt has soared past 26
trillion what impact do you think
that's to have on the value of the
dollar who's paying for it all
fact if you don't think we're sitting on
a house of cards you're living with your
head in the sand
do not wait for the bottom to fall out
now is the time to protect your savings
including your ira
or 401k gold thrives in uncertain times
like these in fact amidst the turmoil
of the past few months gore gold has
soared to an all-time high
the company i trust with precious metal
purchases is birch gold group
thanks to a little-known irs tax law you
can even move your iora
or eligible 401k into an ira backed by
physical gold and silver it's perfect
for those who want to protect our
hard-earned retirement savings
from any more uncertainty or downturns
in stocks i mean it's pretty [ __ ]
simple guys
if you want to just trust the market
which is going to go up and down and
bottom out
and you know it's it's a roller coaster
and if you if you want to play those
games play those games but if you
literally
want to be able to have the peace of
mind to count on your retirement
converting a portion of your ira or 401
or the whole thing
into precious metals you now have the
stability and the peace of mind of
knowing that that
is going to be much better than dealing
with the volatile stock markets just
what it is i'm not making this up i'm
not trying to sell you anything here
even though technically i
am and i'm getting paid to do it i'm
really not
do you understand what i'm saying do you
get that
i'm concerned for you my focus
really has been you and your retirement
plan
and i think about it at night i toss and
i turn i'm very anxious about
your retirement and what you're gonna do
and i think i think to myself i go you
know
i hope they're not just gonna you know
you just put it all in the casino of the
market i hope they back some of this up
by
physical precious metal and gold i mean
that's very important
so if you contact burj gold group to
request a free info kit on physical
precious metals see if diversifying into
gold
makes sense for you this comprehensive
20 page
kit reveals how gold and silver can
protect your savings and how you can
legally move your rra or 401k
out of risky stocks and bonds and into a
precious metals ira
to get your no cost no obligation kit
text tim tim
247 4747 for a limited time see how you
can qualify for up to ten thousand in
free precious metals on your purchase
so guys just text tim tim two four seven
four seven four seven and for limited
time you can potentially qualify for ten
thousand dollars
am i reading that right of free precious
metals i mean
think about it i mean this is a
no downside
situation you you text it you you read
about it if it makes sense for you great
if not it doesn't but let's be very
honest this probably makes sense
for a fair amount of you that have a
roth ira
or a 401k that's eligible to do this
it's very important
and um you know i went
and i spoke to my father about doing
this
the other day i spoke to my father about
doing this and he was a little
apprehensive about it
um and i i i killed him
you know what i you know what i mean
because that's how passionate i am i
didn't mean to but i started
blood i started bludgeoning him
and and i wouldn't stop and i watched a
life
train out of his eyes i'd rather that
than a financially ignorant ogre
as my father
text him four 24747
four seven nate bergman is making his
solo debut that's already being
described as classic rock
by classic rock magazine as otis redding
crossed with bruce springsteen
making instantly likable tunes and hold
their own he is currently in nashville
finishing up his debut album with grammy
winning producer vance powell
good for nate classic rock magazine says
bergman is one of the most original
voices in modern music
and distorted sound describes his first
solo show in london
as a jaw-dropping performance for fans
of chris stapleton sturgell simpson
jason isabelle black crows bruce
springsteen tom petty
right now for a limited time the music
is being offered exclusively through
patreon at patreon.com
nate bergman sings for five dollars a
month the patreon features exclusive
studio songs live streams and a weekly
stories about 18 years of international
touring and recording nate bergman's a
good friend of the show this guy's the
real deal
he's a great musician he wants to get
his name out there and his music out
there he was the lead singer of a band
called lionized for years they toured
internationally domestically
and he's trying to get out there you
could follow nate bergman twitter.com
nate bergman sings instagram nate
bergman sings
n-a-t-e b-e-r-g-m-a-n
exactly like it sounds you could go to
natebergmansings.com or you could go to
patreon.com
nate bergman sings nate is somebody
who's always putting out good stuff and
good content we do appreciate that he
um you know really you know supports the
show
chooses to advertise here um
you know i appreciate you know i played
a song for my
my aunt uh that nate naper and winsang
and she didn't like it and i killed her
i started choking her and
she turned blue she died much quicker
than i thought she would have i
think she had coven and i didn't
want to
let her live if her taste was that bad
because it was a really good song and i
liked it i think it was called the
middle of the end it was about
you know he's kind of lifted that from
my show and you know i didn't give him
any reprisals but i
certainly could call a lawyer and i
might but i appreciate that he's
advertising and i won't
i won't i don't own that phrase but i
mean it's
certainly being repurposed without my
knowledge but that's okay
uh we appreciate him we want you to go
be his fan go
support him on social media go follow
him go subscribe to the patreon go you
know go support local artists and you
know
he's maybe not local to you but who
gives a [ __ ] it's really the idea of it
isn't it so nate
bergman n-a-t-e-b-e-r-g-m-a-n
just get out there on google find nate
bergman
find them you just gotta throw them into
google twitter instagram
patreon nate bergman sings you can find
it pretty easily for five dollars a
month
you know he's putting his music out
exclusively through that
that seems like the new way things are
happening and uh
we really appreciate that so thank you
to nate and go find him
i saw a lot of people you know i visited
friends of mine when i was here this is
an audio only episode we didn't know he
couldn't
you know don't start with me people
please
the amount of content that you are
provided for free there is no generation
of comedians
that has provided as much content uh as
my generation has
absolutely free for you and that doesn't
mean that i don't appreciate all the
money that you guys give us on patreon
i do it we try to put it to good use to
make videos and have fun and do whatever
but the reality of the situation is uh
you know just
if if you forgot what i what i what i
look like
just find me google image me and you can
stare at that
while you listen to this show but i did
i saw some old friends and some
parents of old friends and it's just
depressing um we're all getting older
everybody's getting older i mean that's
the only way to say it
um the good times are over
and i don't mean forever and i don't
even mean for the country even though i
you know i've made that case ad nauseam
um i mean for the friendships
that you had um
the golden age is over um
now there is not much left
there's not much left and that's sad but
there's something
nice about there's something that you
know uh
definitive about that where you can look
at
people and go wow because you know
that's where you really appreciate
time when you look at people that you
used to be
really close with and then you pull back
and you see them later on
and you're in a different place and
they're in a different place
and you barely know each other that's
when you start appreciating time you go
wow you know that's a mind [ __ ]
when you when you when you kind of pull
back and you go you know i was so tight
with that person
i was so close with that person and uh
now i i you know i'm struggling for
things to say
you know within a few minutes i'm
struggling for things to say we're
making inane
meaningless small talk and these are
people that i used to
you know we used to conversations were
effortless
there was always something to talk about
now they're feeling me out and i gotta
feel them out about how political can it
get and
and everybody knows where i stand on
everything i'm not like a
private person but like it's still weird
when you're when you're in a room with
people they're like well are you really
that guy are you that guy are you this
guy who are you and
they don't know what they can say and
it's odd because these are the people
that you
really you know spent a lot of time with
and you had a very organic and natural
relationship
with these people and then you just
gotta you look at it and go well
that's over you know especially when you
sober up everybody on long island's
still boosting it up
and they don't care i mean they don't
care and god love them god bless them
and i mean people in long island they'll
tell you
they survived a brain aneurysm without
blinking i mean they'll
they'll light up a cigarette and go yeah
they found me on the floor i was
bleeding out
they said it was an aneurysm you know i
don't know pulmonary embolism maybe it
was a
yeah i think i had a few pulmonary
embolisms in my left lung i cough one up
over
uh breakfast and uh and they'll be just
sitting there drinking the vodka and
telling you they'll tell you
they'll tell you right to your face and
you're like oh my god is are you okay is
this okay yeah yeah i'm fine it's okay
don't worry about it
don't worry about it you know just
lighting a butt drink yeah yeah yeah it
was a
i had a corn area at artery bypassed it
was a ah you know all of my heart valves
were clogged
uh at maximum and i uh i just woke up
and they say it
so nonchalantly and and it's everything
that's they
every decision they've ever made in
their life is leslie has led up to that
so i get why they say and i'll probably
say one day without being shocked i'd be
like right i just
woke up and i took a breath and i
couldn't breathe and i fell down on my
face
and you'll be telling someone who's not
at that point in their life
and there's something so crazy about the
nonchalant way they just kind of go over
all their health problems and then just
put the butt right back in their mouth
and light it up and then just start
drinking again like nothing ever
happened they'll just tell you they go
yeah i was clinically dead for eight
minutes
yeah clinically dead for eight minutes
and then they brought me back and
i remember the paddles i remember the
cold paddles on my
chest and i remember
there was there was a dark tunnel i was
in a dark tunnel
and i felt like there were these beings
grabbing me and pulling me into hell
ah and then they'll just light up a
cigarette and fall back in their chair
and they're like
but you know i mean things are good all
the tests are good now and i'm like oh
okay well good to see ya
glad i came by hope everyone's well
give my best to everybody i mean
people that stay in the northeast just
get hit with a shovel
there is no way out a lot of people that
leave the northeast
end up for whatever reason you know
extending their life by a few years
not that that's always preferable but
you know i was in the fat store dxl in
palm desert before i flew to new york
and uh
you know the worst uh employees of the
fat store are ones that try to make it
like a nice experience because
it by its very nature is um
uh a disgraceful
experience you have to try on clothing
and see what makes you look less fat i
mean it's the whole point of the fat
store
how do you look less fat by the clothing
that you put on it's not it's never
what makes you look good it's never that
it's a
lesser of two evils
situation it's voting it's voting in
america
it's there's no real like there's no jfk
moment in the fat store where you grab a
shirt and you're like
this is it there's none of that there's
no hope and change
there's no there is none of that there
is just the harsh
cynical realism of what is available
what will look okay on you what will
look
decent what will not cause people to
vomit when you walk in a room
and what can survive the rinse cycle and
that you won't spend 90
on a shirt and then pull it out and then
after the rinse cycle it's now over
and i've had those experiences where you
pull the shirt out of the rinse cycle
and you go this is done i can admit it
to myself
or i can deny it i can lay on my bed and
then pull the shirt and i can tuck my
knees under it
and try to stretch it back out okay and
i've done that many times
but we're also gonna have to be honest
sometimes it goes through the washer and
dryer and then that's it
it's a one and done that's a one and
done sometimes
um and i'm in the fat store and i try
not to speak to any of the people that
work there i'm always polite i'm almost
hey
how are you do you have this in this or
you have you know but i'm never like
how's your day
you know and uh see this guy starts
talking to me and he goes well what part
of new york are you from and i'm like
long island you know and he goes oh
that's great he goes you know
he goes you live here now i said yeah i
live here he goes don't you notice
that when you go on facebook like he
goes right into it and i'm like uh
automatically you know already feeling
nauseous i'm like oh boy
he goes oh you notice when you go on
facebook everybody from the northeast
they look
shot and everybody that got out of there
they seem a little happier and i'm like
yeah i gotta be honest
you're right about that then he goes
like this to me he goes
he looks at me goes did you hear about
that actress
who got murdered the other day and i
said
what he goes that actress who got
murdered
she's famous rhys he goes
she was like stabbed with a knife
because her name's like reese
like reese i'm like reese witherspoon
and he goes no with a knife
and i'm like
what a what a what a life this guy has
just trying to slip that joke into every
conversation
with a fat person in the palm desert
mall
like every every [ __ ] guy in there
some guys much fatter than me like
buying like five x's and [ __ ]
this guy is just looking for an
opportunity to slip
the reese witherspoon with a knife joke
in there but he was right about the east
coast he was certainly right about that
um and i don't know i mean it's one of
those situations where
you you you love the idea that at some
point you you can you can
you can do you can get you know you can
find
some value in the p like in the
in the in the people that you spent all
those years with and not that they
aren't
tremendously valuable but i mean like
you wanna you wanna be able to talk to
them the way you used to talk to them
it's just impossible
it's impossible you know i don't know
that it has anything to do with my
career or anything like that maybe some
of it does i don't think so
i think it's just because i made it out
i got out
i think i got out and i'm doing okay and
there's there's the people that get out
and then the people that don't get out
and then the people that get out are you
know just they're out they're on a
journey and then the people that didn't
get out
you know kind of look at those people
and they're like yeah
okay sure you know
like you know i said to somebody my
friend's mother i said hey i got a house
palm springs i rented it for a few
months if you ever want to get out of
new york
you come over there and uh you can stay
with me if you want you know she's like
how do you have that
it's like her first you know i don't
know i'm selling drugs like what's the
answer you know
like oh you know the podcast has done
well and everything and
you know again it's just a house with a
few bedrooms it's not you know
this is the hamptons estate it's the
home
how do you have that and it's like well
there's the warm long island
you know reception i've been i've been
waiting for
she looks at me she goes you guys
were the needy generation you always
wanted things you needed things
i'm like well also but your generation
of parents was also like you guys were
like
the boomer generation of like hey
you were really and it's so funny i love
this woman she's a great lady
but she always wanted to leave new york
like she was always talking about buying
a condo and getting out of new york
and then i asked her i'm like you ever
think about you know get out of here i
know you talked about florida for many
years i mean
and when i say she talked about it i
mean every conversation that
she had when we were young she found a
way to inject it into
uh the conversation that she wanted to
move to florida you know or
or the carolinas or somewhere and i'm
like you ever think about
you ever think about leaving you know
now you have covid and the city and she
goes where am i gonna go
my friends are here i'm like okay yeah
she goes i'm alone i don't want to go
somewhere now and be a lot you know and
i'm like i understand that's those are
all good reasons
so that's it man that's the thing with
long island you know
no matter how strong the bluff is
nobody's leaving
they're just not going they're not
leaving
i was for sure certain that this lady
would have a place and do like six
months six months
but you get to a certain age where
you're like why am i going to leave
everything that i know because at a
certain age that is all you have
familiarity
is all you have at a certain age because
you're tired
but knowing that you know the people in
the neighborhood you know the stores you
know the restaurants you know the street
signs
you know the stop lights you probably
even know a few of the cops you know the
way
things work you are you know comfortable
and that is what you have that is the
only thing left
and there there's a sadness to that in a
way because we we tend to think of
life being an adventure and it's about
new things and it's about
you know challenging yourself or
whatever and you know i think at a
certain age
all of those things um uh no longer
uh present themselves as exciting
they present themselves as terrifying
and
most people and sometimes that age is 23
you know sometimes
people just settle in and they just dig
in and they stay
where they are and there's no better
example of that that i know about than
you know long island
because the you know a lot of people um
and then some people of course leave
long island and they they go be you know
racist in north carolina or something
they
you know it's not the physical it's not
really the physical space some of them
just
you know get out and you know take your
values with them you know
it's not you know it's not exactly
necessarily confined to a geographic
location
but it's just funny uh you know and then
you wanna you wanna and you don't know
what you're expecting that's the other
thing when you go back and see people
you you kind of don't know what to
expect
you don't know if they're gonna be like
oh my god it's so great to see you and
give you a hug and you know and now this
covert thing is [ __ ] weird you walk
in you don't know hey can i
do i elbow bump you i'd rather do
nothing
like if i'm not gonna give you a hug can
i just like not do anything
uh do we elbow bump do we fist bump
do i do a black power bump to you
i don't know how do we how do we
navigate this insanely awkward moment
right now that we're having like walking
in
having not seen you know people for
years and then
you know basically not being able to
go up to them and hug them um
it's [ __ ] weird every interaction
feels like a weird
interview where you feel like you're
interviewing for a job
and it's a job you don't want and that's
every interaction
the majority of them that i've had this
week not all of them we had a lot we had
a cool lunch
um uh with a very smart person but
the the majority of these interactions
that
we've had have been you know kind of
awkward
stilted uncomfortable uh
interviews where it's like so how have
you been faring
so how have you been have you known
anyone who has died because you're
across a room by the way
so you're not near any once you've got
to be across your room do you know
anyone who has died from this
or not remember your cousin jenna
yes she's dead now
jenna died you know jenna she had lupus
jenna had lupus she was overweight she
was joe's daughter
i don't know remember she sang at mary's
wedding
did she die of colvin they think so
you know it's good to see you
california it's whatever
i mean what are you gonna [ __ ] do you
gotta do these things right you gotta
see these people
i had lunch with my father you know my
father's like
my father's a guy he was like i love him
to death but he's like
he's never worked a high pressure job in
his entire life
and he acts like he's like works on wall
street or something
like he has the energy of a guy that's
like like a doctor in an er
but he just sells wine and it's like
kind of like a relaxing job
he just kind of like he you know it's
like people are drinking wine and they
sell
i mean it's just not it's not like this
crazy
job that you know you know but yeah like
he's always like on his phone he's like
oh boy
oh boy i don't know napa valley's on
fire again i'm like
what do you care what are you kid gonna
retire in a year you're worried about
napa valley being on fire
who gives a [ __ ] he's he acts like he's
like he's like a secret service agent
and he's just he's gonna have to take a
bullet for somebody like that's that's
that's the way the guy acts he's like he
acts he's just always in
like some frenzied that's the thing in
long island man they just
they're always in long island everybody
there is just barely surviving
they all have homes cars bills are all
paid but they're all like i just
i'm just barely hanging on or being
we're being attacked
we're fighting wars on multiple fronts
here
it's just bad it's just been rough here
he's like the city is [ __ ] up he
hasn't been a city in decades you know
the city they're killing everyone in the
city now
and i'm like that's that's true and i've
i've been vocal about that that's not a
good thing
but uh yeah you know my dad's always had
that energy of just a guy who's like
just a guy that's got a lot on his plate
just a guy who's got a lot on his plate
and by that you know it will be like
he'll like
that like the day we met him for lunch
that was probably the one thing on his
calendar
was that we would have lunch with him
and you know again he's just
acting like you know after that he's got
to go and like you know
i don't know like run a presidential
campaign
like are you doing something i don't
know are you walter white
are you doing something i don't know
about are you i are you running some
kind of drug empire
because you're you're acting but that's
just long island
you're fried you're just so fried
uh by the end of your life for all these
sacrifices that you've made to live in
this place
that's taken everything from you and
giving you a small amount in return
uh there's the synapses are gone
you know like i think ben said to my dad
at one time during dinner he's like
what do you think of cuomo my dad's like
look
my dad's like i'm not a political person
and then launches into a screed
right i'm not a politician i'm not a
political person
but here is my 10-point plan
to fix now listen
let me preface this by saying i'm not a
political person
now please direct your eyes to this
chart that i've brought with me
to help you visualize the points i'm
about to make i have a 10-point plan to
fix things
growing up i loved cereal
um it was one of my favorite things um
one of one of my favorite things was if
i ate cereal loudly enough because it
was a lot it's a loud crunchy food
if i ate it loudly enough i could drown
out the sound of my parents screaming at
each other
about money and when you when you have a
real good crunch
you you don't hear the screaming the
endless screaming
about money that they did every night
because they were both lazy
uh pieces of [ __ ] but
what's important here is that we don't
eat sugar
we can all we can all be honest about
that right no matter how we choose to
raise or not raise our children
what's important is that we don't feed
them sugar if you care about your
children
many of you don't but let's just say you
do or if you care about your
bodies and many of you don't but
i'll tell you this this is the sugar
cereal without sugar
how it has zero grams of sugar
11 grams of protein and only three net
grams of
carbs in each serving it's keto friendly
gluten free grain free soy free low carb
and gmo free it comes in four flavors
cocoa
fruity frosted and blueberry
okay i like fruity because it tastes
exactly like froot loops
and i really enjoy fruit loops i will
list now sugar cereals that i like
i like apple jacks but only in the fall
i enjoyed lucky charms
but whatever i liked corn pops
i liked obviously honey nut cheerios
i liked uh
froot loops i was never a pebbles kid i
was never into like cookie crisp or
count chocula or cocoa pebbles or cocoa
crispy or any of that horse [ __ ]
rice krispies was fun every now and then
like if i was going sugar cereal
i'm going i mean i wasn't even that much
in a waffle crisp
or stuff like that i think ben was a
waffle crisp kid what were you
like what was your sinful cereal what
was your cereal that you really
smacks and stuff like that yeah
i like frosted flakes smacks is okay but
like
you ever get an apple jacks a little bit
yeah dude i love golden grahams that was
my [ __ ]
cinnamon toast crunch was my [ __ ] you
ever get into uh
what are you laughing at uh i did what
were you about to say
i'm asking you if you're well what
cereals you're gonna say captain crunch
you're laughing like a psychopath like
the joker over there i'm i'm trying to
talk to you about the
the product that's advertising on the
show uh
i've had captain crunch i like it but
then they got nuts with the crunch
berries and [ __ ] but i enjoyed captain
crunch
what else tell me the other honeycomb
what
the honeycomb remember yeah i actually
had that a few times i did enjoy it
it's not bad yeah
magic spoon is really good because
it simulates the experience of all of
the cereals we've mentioned
all these sugar cereals you've not had
since you're a kid and you
crave especially if you're on a keto
diet it's very hard to have three keto
meals
right now this is one of your meals
it's a literal meal it's perfect 11
grams of protein
you do a little yogurt with it some
fruit and at the end you know
you know keto approved fruit of course
um
and you've wiped one meal off
the planning of the day you know
um and that's so important
for planning it's it's so easy it's you
don't need to meal prep it it's right
there
it goes right in the thing you go to
magicspoon.com tim dillon grab a variety
pack try today
use our promo code tim dillon at
checkout now some people come to me and
they go
oh tim the cereal is a little expensive
and i'm like well what do you think
you know the operation is going to be to
drain your daughter's diabetic foot
you think that'll be expensive you think
it's going to be expensive
like when they have when they're
literally draining sewage out of your
your fat child do you think that'll be
expensive
when they have to take your violet
beauregard fat blueberry of a daughter
and take her into the juicing part of
the wonka factory
because that's what the [ __ ] it is out
there so maybe spend a little [ __ ]
money
and invest in some health go to
magicspoon.com
tim dillon ridge wallet
yum bridge wallet is the easiest
sleek slim front-facing front pocket
wallet
the easiest wallet to sanitize the
easiest wallet
to to carry you stay safe
it doesn't bulge out of your pocket it
does not advertise
you have a wallet on you you are not a
target
if you're living in one of these cities
that's rapidly disintegrating
easily as you sanitize your hands you
can take out your your small
metallic carbon fiber or titanium ridge
wallet
and sanitize your wallet as well this is
really
um a product that's really of the now
it's so important um it's a minimal
wallet man and it's got thirty thousand
five star reviews it's a better way to
carry your
cash and your cards and it's so easy to
keep clean
and it's easy to keep track of and it
helps you streamline your entire
disorganized life
into a small metallic wallet where you
have a few cards
maybe 100 bill a little bit of cash on
you maybe a 50 a couple of 20s but again
very simple streamlined organized wallet
it is so important so so important to
have that now and very easy to sanitize
and that is maybe
maybe the most important thing right now
get 10 off today
10 off that's a lot of money with free
worldwide not that it's expensive
either but 10 of anything is a lot
with free worldwide shipping and returns
by going to ridge.com
tim that's ridge.com and use the code
tim tim in the description
do you understand what i'm telling you
telling you to go to ridge.com
tim use promo code tim in the
description you're going to get 10
off get free worldwide shipping
and returns if you don't like it which
you will this
is the wallet the official wallet of the
timberland show we
all have ridge wallets we appreciate the
ridge company
um you know ben has him he's got a rich
backpack i mean
he's got everything i don't know are
they even for sale the backpack
yeah they are they are they're just a
quality uh they're a quality operation
across the board ridge
and i i definitely you know recommend
that you go
and grab a wallet and please use the
promo code unlike my father who bought a
ton and forgot to use the promo
code because he's still trying to
destroy me
but please use the promo code
and it supports the show it lets them
know that we're doing a good job
and i'm telling you if it was if it
wasn't a good wallet i would tell
you not to get it but it's a good wallet
it keeps you
[ __ ] organized and it forces you to
throw out all the garbage the crap
the business cards the old hotel room
keys
you know it's it's not a big catcher's
mid a big leather
[ __ ] pouch that you pull out of your
[ __ ]
pants this is a sophisticated
futuristic sleek wallet
and as soon as bill gates finds a way to
put this wallet in your arm you're not
even going to need it
but for right now you need it ridge.com
tim i want to talk about another below
deck
podcast that's what i want to do because
i the show below deck is good we don't
know why it's good but it's good
it's interesting people on yachts are
interesting they're demanding
and then the people that work on yachts
are kind of people that
are fun to watch but you also don't care
if they die
you know because those people for the
most part are like
they're like galley slaves you know what
i mean they're like scallywags or
whatever they're like
they're just monsters you know they just
take those jobs because they want to get
hammered
and they want to [ __ ] hang out on the
yacht we can't respect those people
but in a way we want to watch them and
we want to watch them we want to see
them have fun
and we want to we we want to watch them
clean
and then party and we want to watch them
[ __ ] up and get reprimanded and grow up
right before our eyes but it's not
enough to just watch the show
i want to hear more about it i want to
talk about it
i want to be able to hear funny people
break it down
um so that's why we have to listen to
another below deck
podcast okay i just enjoy it
and what what who's it's theovon's
producer nick
it's hosted by dylan nick and pat dylan
nick and pat
who are i mean i i don't use the word
creative heroes
a lot but let's just say it applies to
all of them
now who is this [ __ ] they had kate i
like kate who do they have ron
they had on kate chastain yeah she's
like the head [ __ ] i'm below deck
i'm kind of impressed that they got her
but they got her because they're running
a tight ship no pun intended they're
running a tight ship over there
at another below deck podcast and they
got kate chastain
and they really went to town now what
happened somebody got fired
yes the firing of chief stu hannah
for she had drugs on the yacht i don't
i'm trying to find out
what chief stu hannah what kind of drugs
did she have
i'm gonna look it up right now because
uh
i just found out tori lanez shot megan
the stallion i don't know who any of
these people are
uh i just maybe we shouldn't
maybe we shouldn't i mean i don't know
should all the musicians always be
shooting each other all the time
is that good for the kids am i
officially old that i'm starting to
notice these things
is it good for the kids if all the
musicians are shooting each other in the
face all the time
is that good or no i don't know
she had a valium pills and a cbd pin
i mean that's weak [ __ ] they kicked you
off for a valium and a cbd
pen who gives a [ __ ]
dude what's going on in this country
i don't i don't understand what is her
name can you spell it please
hannah um farrier
f-e-r-r-i-e-r
she goes it's not something i was hiding
about the valium
i think i've just been really
disappointed because i feel i'm being
painted as some sort of drug addict
yeah i mean this is weak dude
but apparently this kate chastain hates
her
right is that what it says this is sort
of unfair because apparently
she's been having like panic attacks on
board and stuff
they just kicked her off huh well they
just kicked her yeah but you know she
could [ __ ] say anything she wants
i've been having panic attacks and i
that's why i need to valium and
you know my my wrists get lonely that's
why they need the needle in them
yeah i mean it's like who knows
but i i do think the podcast is
worthwhile give it a give it a listen
you know and see what you think i mean
if you're into that show below deck it
is a good
show you know i mean if people like it i
mean these guys are into it and they do
another podcast about the bachelor
called another bachelor podcast
you know they stay up on these shows and
a lot of people you know when you're
done with this show if none of your
friends watch it maybe you watch it in
secret maybe you shamefully watch it you
don't want to admit you watch it none of
your friends
want to talk to you about it you can
then you know listen to this podcast
because
maybe you know if you admit hey i watch
below deck one of your friends is gonna
be like listen
i mean you know have you ever thought
about [ __ ] a dude you're gonna be
like i did in college a few times and
then it's gonna be [ __ ] weird
and then your friend comes over and you
guys start [ __ ] you know
and you're not ready for that and it all
started because you admitted to watching
below deck and then all of a sudden
he's taking you below deck you know and
he's teaching you how to prepare
the bottom and you have to clean up and
then you're sitting there eating dinner
with your wife and
you just got [ __ ] in the ass viciously
and there's an oddness to it and you're
like
you know it wasn't entirely you know it
wasn't unenjoyable but
now you have this entire crisis that's
brewing in your life
because you didn't just listen to
another below deck podcast
you had to admit to a friend that you
like below deck
which then led to him [ __ ] you
on the bed where you sleep with your
wife
i mean do you see what i mean
so where can they go they are on
apple podcasts and on spotify and if you
want to leave a review on apple podcast
saying you heard about the show on the
tim dillon show
i would love that if you did that for me
personally you know i if you if you went
to apple podcast
yeah i heard about this from the tim
dylan show that would if you guys have
any time
you know in in between your busy day of
doing whatever
you know uh if you could do that for me
that would be really good
also you know check out the podcast i i
think it's a real
uh it's a good podcast uh if you're not
if you're into below deck i like you
know below decks a show that i could
just kind of watch
you know when i was on the road i'd put
it on it'd be a marathon of bravo i just
watched four hours of it
while i just laid in a hotel room bed in
ohio and wished i was dead
and i would just watch the show and it
was really it was just like fun because
i like bo i like seeing boats and stuff
all right but i've been here a week i'm
here a few more days ben's flying out
tomorrow morning and then i'm back to
the desert we're really locking this
[ __ ] up we're locking it up
unfortunately i know that a lot of you
want to go out and see me live and i
want to go out and
i want to perform live but we're locking
this baby up until 2021 because the
reality is
i'm not having you guys go out and buy
tickets to shows that don't [ __ ]
happen
i don't want clubs holding your money i
don't want you to keep being rescheduled
you know these things to keep being
rescheduled
and then you don't get a refund and i
know you guys need your [ __ ] money
it's a [ __ ] rough time out there i
will get back into this
when there's something to get back into
and i think i said that a few months ago
and i meant that
this was my test of the waters here to
see how this would be
you know i was never thrilled about
performing in a tent i didn't want to do
it
it was an interesting experiment i think
it would have been a lot of fun
and it may uh you know it might have
made me consider
you know potentially entertaining some
other kind of
you know experimental shows
that were safe and socially distanced
but now
i'm pretty convinced that until the
election
especially in in blue states but but in
all states really um we're not going to
see
um a ton of forward
motion and progress i think the system
is gummed up
right now and i think that there needs
to be some resolution
uh whichever way uh in a few months and
then people are gonna you know respond
to that i do think hopefully
after the winter by the spring of next
year we're back up and running and
that's really not that long
you know we have we have september
october november december january
february we have six solid months
of whatever is happening here but i do
believe that by march or april of next
year
we might have heard immunity there might
be a vaccine treatments have gotten
better
testing has gotten better diagnostics
that's really all we need
is better testing to figure out who's
got this and who doesn't
um and then we kind of move forward with
it and i do believe the tone of the
coverage will change
if trump is out of office i think even
if he wins reelection
the tone of the coverage will change
because it will go from being this major
political story
to just a story and there's a very
there's a big difference between
a story with a hell of a lot of
political significance in an election
year
and a regular story that's what it is um
my feud and war with the cuomo family i
imagine will continue
they don't like me i don't like them
there are probably high level meetings
about what to do with me
what to do with this populist this
william jennings bryant type
this guy who's running around in tents
preaching the good word
telling the people the truth at
tremendous risk to his
personal physical emotional safety
dealing with this you know this this
this this
gangster and his family
that are incredibly powerful some would
say all-powerful in the state
i wouldn't but some would
okay and they focused their
sights on me they have focused the scope
of their rage and their animosity
at me but that is okay because i do not
shrink
i will not be intimidated
by this family of goons i will not be
intimidated by them i know who they are
i know what they want to be i can see
through their lies
i can see through their distortions i
would never trust
anybody whose one brother was the
governor and the other brothers
an anchor on cnn could you think of any
more contemptible family
i mean i would rather i would rather you
know spend time with a family of
cannibals
do you realize how much more class
jeffrey epstein and justlane maxwell
have than these two pigs
do you have any idea can you even fathom
in your mind
okay the code that epstein and maxwell
live by that these [ __ ] garlic knots
not for a minute in their [ __ ] life
now i'm not defending maxwell and
epstein
in fact quite the opposite i am just
saying do you have any idea how bad
these people are that run the state i
don't think you know
i don't think you know because it is fun
because the garlic bread is nice
because the lobster fra diablo is nice
but the criminality the criminality
is uh and i love the mafia by the way i
love the mob
i don't mind the mob i grew up with the
mob
respect to the mob but this government
like drunk on their own power
it is absolutely disgusting
they should be in them they should have
just been actual gangsters
actual mobsters they would have been
much happier
but instead they're on cnn
why i'm i'm i'm
truly appalled and i do believe i do
believe there is a chance
this was a personal i do believe it
could have been a vendetta
do you believe that 100 i do believe it
um because this club had opened
uh it had been functioning
and they shut it down a few hours before
my show and i believe this is a vendetta
against me
no rival clubs either right there's no
rival clubs that are that are you know
because sometimes you have that problem
where a rival club will inform on
another club but no i mean this seems to
be this seems to be a situation
and here's the reality i i they're
trying to discourage me from
from from doing business in my home
state it will not happen
it will not happen in fact i will i will
i will i will show up
with with uh candace owens
and i will throw a freedom freedom
concert
i will have a freedom concert with
candace owens
and i will i will sing
[Music]
uh you know patriotic songs
with candace owens and they can shut
that let him shut that down
let him put me in candace and cuffs and
take us away
you know there's going to be a protest i
think governors are going to protest
this
we got to take it all the way to albany
the fight must we must fight
for our right to see comedy in a tent
because folks they're not stopping i
mean these people aren't giving back the
powers that we've given them over the
last four months
and i told you i never said corona was
fake i think it's real it's brutal
it's it's it's nasty it's random
all of those things are true they're
still true but
i've also said when you give
muscles marinara all the power in the
world
and then you expect him to give it back
it's not
going to happen so then you're left with
a situation where you've given
politicians
more power in the last five months than
you've given them in the last 10 years
they are drunk on that power okay they
are literally telling you
how and when you can earn a living you
are depending on
on them for your income you are
depending on them for
um guidance in all matters of public
health
you were depending on them uh in terms
of educating your children
you were depending on them it is a
position that i that i it is terrifying
for anyone that appreciates freedom um
uh to any degree the position that
people in this country are in right now
is a terrifying
position and and uh you know it's not
like some you don't have to be some
crazy libertarian
to believe that just pay attention you
look at the way things are going
um and you know you got what's allowed
what's allowed today am i allowed to do
this can i do that can i walk on a beach
can i walk on a trail can i breathe air
can i breathe air today is air allowed
today
what's allowed what's not allowed is
this the day that i'm allowed to go to
the beach or someone else allowed to go
to bed like
you know what's allowed here
what's not violating a town ordinance or
law or rule and if the guy five people
over my house now the government until
uh
they'll just shut the power off to the
house now i mean folks
wake the [ __ ] up wake up
they're shutting the power off to your
house this happened
to some good kids in la uh uh the sway
tick tock house
now these these gentlemen uh are trying
to
just again you know
you know uh enrich the culture
of the city of los angeles by making
people happy
uh by dancing and
you know having raging parties you know
wild ragers they just wanna they just
wanna rage they're young kids and they
just
they wanna jump around and take their
phones out and they wanna do drugs they
want to scream and yell
and they want to [ __ ] and terrorize
their neighbors and
you know make a lot of money and then
lose it and you know they want to have
the kind of fun that often destroys the
lives of people around them including
sometimes their own and i i think that
that's
what should happen i do i
i think that's what los angeles is about
it's
it's about a group of children to move
into a house and to destroy an entire
community i you know i kind of believe
that whereas new york is not about that
it's
has it has a dignity to it that los
angeles just doesn't have
you know those kids are followed around
by paparaz i mean it's like yeah of
course
and they cut the power off to the tick
tock house because those kids wouldn't
stop
and i mean isn't it ironic that they're
the real americans
is it ironic to you that the tick tock
house is actually
the minute men they're the real american
they're george washington
they're they're hiding in the trees
jumping out to try to get the redcoats
they're storming the beaches of normandy
by doing
renegade renegade that's
a literal protest they're the americans
they went from being [ __ ] like a few
months ago when they were just
you know before the quarantine they were
just having these loud parties of people
trying to sleep and you know but now
i'm in full support i i would
i would love to be invited
and to participate in what i consider
an act of civil disobedience frankly
yes or yes this is an act of civil
disobedience
and we are fighting a totalitarian
government we are fighting it with dance
and we are fighting it with the volume
and we were fighting it with having a
great time
smiling jumping around being loud using
drugs
revving the engines of cars these are
these
went from being things that i would
generally say
no to to now truly believing that this
is an
uh this is an act of resistance
i now believe jake paul and team 10
to be more significant than the founding
fathers
truly at this moment right now
jake paul and his arsenal and his uh
team 10 who have the parties and they go
nuts to me
are the real americans now it is not the
nurses and the doctors i'll tell you
that much
we've all had a bad enough are those
people
crying oh sorry i had to do the job i
signed up to do
what no it's not them and you know what
i've also had enough with the military
sorry i've just had a and i've had
enough with them
i don't mean that permanently i'm sure
that i will i will
appreciate them again but as of right
now i'm not invested emotionally in a
lot of the wars we're in
i just don't i you know to me it's not
um but right now i am seeing
the tick tockers and i'm seeing jake
paul i'm seeing team 10
and i'm seeing these are the people who
i believe will save the country
by partying and by disobeying
laws that are unjust
and and and as much as some of this is
tongue-in-cheek
i it really isn't and i i truly believe
that resistance is not it's not going to
come from
the middle class um
polite respectable people they're just
going to follow
um you know uh governor panini and his
family
uh into a fascist hellscape
but what i count on i count on the youth
i count on
the kind of the rich young rich kids
that drive
fast cars and that don't have any
respect
those are the kids that may save us all
you know and i you know when they took
when they cut the power to those kids
house
you know i was a little disappointed
that those kids kind of
i think they folded a little and i think
what they should have did
was i think they should have taken it to
like the next level
because there's a lot of like you know
protests in front of mayor garcetti's
house in los angeles he lives in hancock
park
but i think the tick tock kids should
have stormed his house
and started partying on his lawn just
started drinking and tick-tocking on his
lawn
and partying pulling out with the
ferraris
and just [ __ ] making content right on
mayor garcetti's lawn and say
this is america [ __ ] what town did you
[ __ ] think you were the mayor of
saga panic what do you think you're the
[ __ ] man
you're the mayor of los angeles okay
this city is built on the bones of
people
that we've sacrificed to ancient gods
and you're shutting my [ __ ] power off
because my music was loud because my
i was listening to the baby at
too loud of a volume do you think you're
the mayor of chicago
or new york or a real place
you're not you're the mayor of los
angeles it's a city that's on fire
most of the year okay
so to deny those young men and women the
chance
to be ridiculous for money for a lot of
money
is to deny the entire ethos of the city
it's not about public health public
health
it's on fire how can it be healthy
you let those [ __ ] dance you
[ __ ] empty suit so as soon as i get
back here i hopefully will be joining
forces with
many of those people and putting
together what i would consider a
paramilitary
unit of them and starting to engage in
uh what the fbi will call localized and
worrisome uh activity
uh which i would call uh freedom
fighting
and the fbi would call domestic
terrorism now
that is
[Laughter]
renegade um
that's that's where you have it folks at
the end of the day this is not a video
episode this is an episode on the fly
we'll be back doing video next week i
will be back
in palm springs back in the desert
seeing where i'm gonna end up some of my
friends going to austin texas
some of them have left and gone back to
new jersey i don't know what to do i
think i might stick it out in la
i might stick it out because that is
where the freedom fighters are
so i might have to stick it out i don't
know not coming back to long island
how'd you get that
what hold on i'm having a stroke
um can't come back to long island sad
but true love everyone here wish them
the best
but you know the times
have gone they've gone now and when
you're when you're drunk and many of you
are drunks out there and
you know you're on drugs or whatever
probably at this very moment
just know that if you have the for you
know the good fortune of sobering up
you know you you know the relationships
you have a lot of the people you you had
you went and drank with are just gonna
change they're gonna be very different
you know it's going to be awkward and
it's going to be you know
kind of strange to see those people you
just start to realize you're like fox
a lot more fun when i was hammered a lot
of these things were a lot more fun when
you were hammered that's just the truth
and that doesn't mean that those weren't
great experiences or valuable
experiences but it means that
it's just a little tough to really you
know
recreate those conditions without a
bottle of gin
you know and uh that's not you know
that's not an invitation to go grab a
bottle of gin either by the way you know
but i mean you know some final parting
words here for the cuomo family i mean
i will continue the fight we were not
ever going to back down
we are never going to roll over we are
never going to
let you turn this uh state this great
state
into uh you know some type of
fascist dictatorship
you know i mean i'll never let it happen
i'll never let you turn the state into
the olive garden
you know you are overstepping your
bounds sir and i'm asking you nicely to
step down
i am saying nicely step down
resign and i'm asking your brother
chris uh fredo cuomo corleone did not
have
coronavirus never forget i'm asking you
to step down sir for lying
for lying uh to the to the nation about
your coronavirus diagnosis
i would like you both to step down and i
would like you to
uh go manage a family-style restaurant
in new jersey
which i think would suit both of you a
lot more because when i look at both of
you i see two people that should be
walking around the floor
asking people how their meal is okay i
don't see you running a state
okay that's the reality and i mean bill
de blasio
i mean that guy i mean should just be
thrown in a van at this point
i mean everybody hates that guy there's
never been a political figure
who's drawn as much ire as this guy
i mean picture jfk like bill de blasio
has as much hatred as jfk
except bill de blasio is doing nothing
like none of the revolutionary things
that jfk was trying to do
and yet somehow bill de blasio has
assembled a coalition that rivals jfk
of people that just hate him like
truly wake up every day hating this
buffoon of the mayor that new york city
has
but but what are you gonna do folks
um i will see everybody back in the
desert we'll be back
uh we've had some fun patreon episodes
we have ray uh
uh last week and ray coming back this
week and then uh we'll be back on
patreon with some cool stuff
coming up we did a fun video about what
what would happen you know a lot of this
uh corporate activism has gotten really
insane and we said well what would be
you know the next step it would be like
a guy training a
you know antifa in his backyard in the
hamptons and uh we did a video and we
it was really fun and we appreciate the
people let us use their yard and they
seemed
they seemed cool with it i mean they
were a little mildly uncomfortable i
think the idea is when somebody like you
know this was brokered through somebody
i don't you know i know the person who
brokered it but i don't know the people
whose yard it is and i don't ever know
who knows me or what i've done or if
they've googled me or whatever
but you know when i show up with eight
people dressed in all black and i start
screaming about hedge funds in the back
of a house
where the guy probably runs a hedge fund
um
you know i'm sure there was you know a
level of discomfort i don't know if it
was mild or extreme
but i appreciate that they let us do
that i didn't think we were gonna you
know we're sitting here last night right
going how are we gonna get a house and
we made it happen we manifested it
it happened as jessa reid would say you
manifested
and it just happened it was a fun video
and of course i'm sure people are ma you
know
people are mad about it one woman one
like old lady tweeted at me she was like
you need to read the bible and stop
eating and i'm like
well one of those things is true
i'll give you 50 of that
old gypsy woman
i mean that's you know you're not wrong
about the whole tweet
i should probably start reading
something i don't know if it's the bible
that seems a little retro
timbalandcomedy.com for all uh you know
live dates that
are not going to happen there are none
uh
uh we have our merch uh we have some new
merch will come out probably before the
holidays we're gonna start banging
people over the head with merch now
we appreciate everybody uh on the
patreon
again this was just a little update out
of new york city
we're in there we're in ham what did you
think of the hampton this was your first
time out
to long island you know this part of
long island which is a very special part
of long island
to me and i like it here because people
don't want me to be here and those are
my favorite places
yeah it's just that little moment of
being uncomfortable
in those places where you're not allowed
where they give you the look and then
yes
you just walk right and you just walk on
the beach yeah no one cares
no but the reality is there's a small
moment of judgment that most people
don't want to go through
it's that little moment of discomfort
that most people avoid their entire
lives because they build it up to be
much more than it is
and that's why people don't succeed at
anything and that's why they waste all
their time on this planet
but i don't waste my time on this planet
i walk right
on the beach at the south hampton
bathing court i don't give a [ __ ] about
nothing
does it matter to me doesn't matter to
me because i smell the garlic
do you understand what i'm saying i
smell it
i smell it through the calvin klein
blouse i smell it through the christian
dior
it doesn't matter it doesn't wash
off okay
so me and you we're one and the same i'm
just an irish
[ __ ] mick who i come from a long line
of people
who [ __ ] sat and got their asses
kicked and threw up and fought in bars
and you come from a long line of [ __ ]
sausage making criminals so don't
we are not that different here and let's
not act like we are
okay okay thanks
but what was your impression of the area
it's these that's enough
ben avery on twitter everybody uh
we appreciate it ben avery is good on
twitter
go get him go ask him his thoughts there
not on my show
not on my show good night